رد الفعل الأكثر شيوعًا الذي نحصل عليه هو أن
طعمه يشبه الدجاج وما
نقوله للناس هو أن هذا هو
الدجاج وأنه مصنوع
بطريقة مختلفة. اسمي جوشوا تيتريك
أنا المؤسس المشارك والرئيس التنفيذي لشركة اللحوم الجيدة
ونحن نحاول أن نصنع لحمًا حقيقيًا
دون الحاجة إلى ذبح
حيوان باللحم المزروع، تبدأ
بخلية ثم تغذي تلك الخلية ثم
تقوم بتصنيعها في
وعاء من الفولاذ المقاوم للصدأ يسمى
مفاعل حيوي أم ثم بعد بضعة أيام تقريبًا
بعد أسابيع تقوم بإزالته من
وعاء الفولاذ المقاوم للصدأ وتحوله إلى
المنتج النهائي الذي هو دجاج على
طبقك أو لحم بقر على طبقك
اليوم، نقوم بهذا الإنتاج في سنغافورة
ونقوم بهذا الإنتاج في شمال
كاليفورنيا في الولايات المتحدة، لذا
بدلاً من عجن مليارات
الحيوانات وذبحها وكل
الأعلاف وكل الأشياء التي تدخل
فيها، يمكننا أن نصنع الدجاج بطريقة أكثر
كفاءة ونعتقد أنها أكثر أمانًا وصحة وأكثر
استدامة ولكنها دجاج، لذا إذا
كنت تعاني من حساسية الدجاج وأنت  إذا أكلت
هذا، فستصاب بتفشي الحساسية،
إذا كنت نباتيًا بشدة
ولا ترغب في استهلاك أي
منتجات حيوانية، فلا يجب أن تأكل هذا بشكل صحيح
لأنه بالتأكيد ليس
نباتيًا عندما تصنع اللحوم المزروعة
بدلاً من اللحوم التقليدية.  لها
العديد من التأثيرات الإيجابية، لذا سأبدأ
بثلث العالم اليوم
المخصص فقط لإطعام الحيوانات، فنحن في
كثير من الأحيان نهدم الغابات المطيرة
لزراعة فول الصويا والذرة لإطعام الحيوانات
كالطعام في عالم حيث اللحوم المزروعة C
مصدر اللحوم المهيمن لا تحتاج
إلى القيام بذلك، يمكننا السماح لهذه الغابات المطيرة
بالبقاء كما هي والسماح
للتنوع البيولوجي بالنمو والازدهار.
عندما تصنع اللحوم المزروعة بدلاً من
اللحوم التقليدية، فأنت لا تتمتع بكل
السلامة الغذائية  مشكلات سواء كانت أنفلونزا أفين أو
مرض البقرة M أو مجموعة من الأمراض الحيوانية المنشأ الأخرى
التي تأتي من حشر الحيوانات
في مساحات ضيقة. فعندما تصنع
اللحوم المزروعة بدلاً من اللحوم التقليدية، فإنك
تصنعها بانبعاثات أقل بكثير، لذا فإن
اللحوم التقليدية مسؤولة عن
انبعاثات الكربون أكثر من أي شيء آخر.
مصادر النقل مجتمعة
يجد معظم الناس أنه من المفاجئ أن هذا
ليس هو الحال مع
اللحوم المزروعة حسنًا، في النهاية نرى
اللحوم المزروعة هي اللحوم لذلك نريدها
أن تكون الغالبية العظمى من اللحوم المنتجة
في جميع أنحاء العالم اليوم أه بالتأكيد
للناس  يهتمون أكثر قليلاً
بالبيئة، ويهتمون
بسلامة الغذاء، ويحبون اللحوم،
ويحبون دجاجهم، ويحبون لحم البقر،
لكنهم يفضلون أن يشعروا
بالتحسن قليلاً حيال ذلك، هؤلاء هم
الأشخاص الذين نستهدفهم اليوم و  نحن
نبيع أكثر من أي شركة أخرى في
العالم عدة مرات ولكن أحجامنا
صغيرة جدًا، لذا نحن في
المراحل الأولى من تحقيق ذلك.
أعتقد أننا جميعًا نستمتع حقًا باللحوم
ولكن أعتقد أيضًا أننا نستمتع أيضًا على الأرجح
أم إلحاق ضرر أقل في حياتنا
وهذه هي الطريقة للقيام بذلك